[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
oh yeah in saudi arabia dude jerking off
in front of a group of women that's a
that's like the
let's make a deal over there you get a
tax break for doing this yeah yeah you
can write that
unbelievable yeah i mean it's crazy you
know
yeah for real it's so funny how we're
like we have to say you know like
every it's sometimes it's funny in
america how it's like everybody's
welcome here you know
but we have to have but then at the same
time those same people will be like
slamming the way that we behave in this
country
yeah but then also the people that they
are totally just willy-nilly
willing to let in behave the way that
we behave that they hate exactly but
just because they're from somewhere else
they can come in
so you're a murderer from [ __ ] you
know slackadakia come on
come on it's like a docus yeah we need
guys like you we need more slackadakians
by the way that is something we should
talk about
we just have all these old white
murderers and black murderers i'm tired
of old white murderers man it's getting
really old
we need some slokadokian you know what i
realized sometimes i don't even really
want to have sex i just want to put my
penis in there
just it just let it sit and soak no just
get as long as you get it in
it's like it's yeah they call it soaking
that's enough really yeah
yeah yeah really hardcore uh mormons
mormons will call it's called soaking
wow they're allowed to put it in they
just can't they just can't make friction
yeah you got it it's hard though you're
gonna sneak it in there and let it sit
for an operation
[Laughter]
i remember this girl i asked her out one
time she said yes and i took her to a
dance and i had a chance to like
take off her underpants one time and it
was just me and her and i [ __ ] got
scared bro you got nervous
yeah well kind of with a granny panty so
hot i don't remember
you she was hot and you got nervous she
was so [ __ ] hot dude
i just went i remember going in the
bathroom and masturbating
to the thought of maybe taking off her
pant that you the fact that you didn't
get to take off her panties and she was
still in the living room when i did it
yeah i get that trust me i've done [ __ ]
like that i just remember sitting on a
pool table
and i like kind of had my hands like on
the upper legs and was just feeling and
we were kissing bro and i was like [ __ ]
dude i'm living my dreams you know
and then i [ __ ] couldn't handle the
pressure you broke huh oh
dude i just remember that i remember
getting scared i was like i'm not going
to get an erection everything this girl
hates me
you did get an erection though i don't
remember and when i went in the bathroom
but it's easy to get in direction to
masturbate you're looking at yourself in
the mirror
no no i looked i only looked at myself
when i jerked off
i would stare right into my eyes in the
mirror yeah right into my eyes oh my god
and then right as i
say theo red as i came i'd wink at
myself
who are you bro [ __ ] dane come on
hannibal
bro okay okay the thing about a guy with
a guy like louie is once you get to that
level of ego and have that much
influence and that much power that's
probably really did happen right i mean
when you're coming in front of people
and running past them and jerking off
i mean everybody come it's hard to do
that but that's a [ __ ] power move
that is powerful
he's just like hey look at these socks
and then they see you're naked and they
look at the socks first
then they see you're naked and then you
come do you remember that game that boys
would play where they'd be like yo what
time is it and they'd wrap their nuts on
their watch and [ __ ] like that
yeah that was pretty preeminent for
louis you think he was doing that when
he was young oh i got some gum and
you know what is that gum yeah yeah
there was always one kid who looked at
it for too long
yeah that was you're like oh look at
this piece of gum and everyone's like oh
and there's one that was like oh
is it grape was there a show
that you liked like what's one of your
favorite reality shows every time did
you ever watch for love or money or any
of those
i loved um what was flavor flav's show
oh yeah i [ __ ] love it
yeah boy when he met new york new york
is crazy son
i love that i thought that [ __ ] was wild
because it was like that dude had no
filter
yeah when i when i first moved here he
didn't give a [ __ ] he gave no [ __ ]
he had like that girl's booty is too
small
and they'd leave it in they didn't even
mean
that's right he's he bro he is he's
easily the first black flavor lover to
conceive a child with a 70 year old wife
i know bro and he's ageless this dude is
this dude this dude will laugh look i'm
going to give you the name
nicorette you know right nicoretta
because you got me quitting all these
other [ __ ]
you know he'd always have like weird
names right
oh your name is booty hole you know when
you're in the hotel room and the
cleaning lady
um they come in they knock and they come
in right away mm-hmm
do you tell them right you go oh stop no
no no no i'm good i'm good or you let
him figure it out
i let him figure it out i just let him
figure it out i sit in bed and i let him
come all the way and they go oh i'm so
sorry i'm like that's okay
that's okay i just let him it's okay i'm
just gonna get new towels i let him in
you're just sitting there naked on the
computer
come on in no that's right just towels
just fine
just sitting there typing away butt ass
naked i stay naked in a hotel
i stay naked oh dude there's something
about hotels a comedian used to do a bit
about it there's something about hotels
where you get in there you gotta get
naked
you gotta get naked out what is that i
don't know well because it's not your
room
you feel naughty you're in somebody
else's room and you just you don't have
any responsibility
if anything goes wrong in there it's not
your problem yeah it's really nice it's
like a rental that you don't
that there's no agreement on you know
what i mean a temporary rental
that if something happened you're just
like that's not me i didn't do that that
was there when i came in
yeah that's the best part there's no
responsibility in hotels you could do
whatever you want you have as many
people there
it's wonderful i know a girl in high
school i used to live in one of those
extended stay hotels
she would have parties every single day
oh wow no consequences
and she was a real party type of girl
[Music]
and her mother was her and a single
mother and her mother uh
was never around because she was working
i never saw her mom
we got to go over that we gotta go to
the extended stay all the time and just
party it was wonderful man you know
little dicky the rapper do you know him
yeah yeah yeah he's a friend and he was
performing there okay and uh we went
there
and uh my lady and a friend um
and another friend of ours they wanted
to see gwen stefani do like one of her
last shows
so i bucked up and i went so i went
stephanie and then i went and saw my boy
little dicky oh hold on
i didn't buck up and go see when
steph i wasn't i
yeah of course i love good stuff i love
gwen stefani but i wasn't like
i wasn't like gotta see her on new
year's eve
40 songs it's like what are these songs
well then she's she's got some cuts she
does she's got some cuts
is winston finding the lady from the
voice too yes
oh that's cool she's married to the dude
that's on the voice no way adam levine
nope blake shelton blake shelton oh
really did he come out
nah he didn't he was back drinking i'm
sure dude come [ __ ] out it's like 30
steps and do a hit
i know i'm mad i was mad i was mad i was
so then what then you and your boy
you're out with a little dickie in vegas
then we went out a little diggy in vegas
yeah we had a good time and then we
ended up at the chainsmokers hotel room
do you know who they are
yeah that band yeah yeah you're
extremely band dropping right now
yeah well i did what i did and how big
was their hotel room
that's funny it wasn't as big as i
thought it was going to be really yeah
because they were like we're going to
the chainsmokers party i was like it's
gonna be [ __ ] wild as [ __ ]
i was amped on the bus i was lit up i
was on the stripper pole doing my thing
everybody's laughing
we get there and i'm like james boga's
hotel room we got viped up there and
everyone's kind of quiet they had a tray
of dessert out i was like this ain't it
oh it's all a lot of work dude have you
ever worked at brenda's shop
it's a lot that's a lot of work that's
an uphill like atlas that guy who pushes
that ball up that hill you ever seen
that guy from greek mythology and it
always keeps falling down on him yeah
and no matter how close you get to the
top it's gonna it's always coming and
then that's that's why is that ball
right sisyphus never was able to get it
up there thick boy was like why does
this ball of a thick boy bite club shirt
dude he loves the biking huh dude it's
crazy i was like is he sponsored by bike
is bike sponsoring him i feel like he he
got so into bikes overnight oh he was
like yeah bro i'm [ __ ] 25 miles today
up this year i'm like good for you dude
dude yeah i'm phony hulk that's it dude
he will
that's the thing about brendan people
knock him the one thing that he is
that that inspires me is that he is a
hard
worker yes he's committed who else can
go from
one thing to the next right he jumps all
right find their footing in it football
fighting com podcasting
comedy and biking and freaking biking
you get sponsored by bike the company
bike it's like q-tip
really all the bikes sponsored him wow
any bike company he wants
thick boy his instagram has become like
an autistic kid's instagram it'll just
be
like big snake on road
pictures of snake yeah like oh yeah
here's a danger noodle yeah he posed a
steak like he hasn't seen he's
you've seen one every day it's not a
mystery anymore now it's it's a nuisance
to me
i'd go god for these [ __ ] snakes he's
like whoa
here's another sand winder whoa
the best is uh the other day he's like
flag sounds of some lady biking
he flags her down and let her know
there's a snake there and she doesn't
give a [ __ ] she's like whatever loser
just drives by is he into motorcycles
does he do is he is he up there yet he
is it's on his calendar but i don't know
i think it's 2022.
2022. he'll get you into those sit bikes
you know with the big sides
like the mexicans have out here yeah
yeah the beach beach cruisers yeah oh no
no i'm talking about the ones where the
older people yeah
and it has like the little case on the
thing for a gatorade yeah a little
picnic basket in the side
yeah oh yeah what got your sandwich in
there honey
you want a bologna i got your bologna
well that's what they did they put up
they put up different things different
videos
all for stuff these are my guys and then
you can scroll through
bleach media official and all he did was
post about
dalia dalia dalia so you think chris was
paying him too
i don't know because he wouldn't make a
dent yeah
that's a lot of money bro he does dude i
was somewhere with him and i've said
this before where a table was uneven
and he took like hundred dollars and
folded it up and put it under the table
just so he could enjoy his coffee and
that's it dude and somebody said he's
been like ordering blood off the
internet and all kind of
yes yeah holder and blood he does the he
does such strange things with money
we go to this coffee shop sometimes and
they have his order ready before you
know he comes in because he goes all the
time yeah
i said that's that's really cool and he
goes yeah but i take care of them i said
what do you mean you take care of him he
says i take care of them don't worry
about it but child support and stuff
yeah
he pays their rent the two girls that
work there pays their rent
pays for their kids a private schooling
yeah it's ridiculous what starbucks
worker
is sending their kid to private
schooling
janiece over on unbelievable
he's got too much money and so this is
this should be a message to your fans
um yeah rob him rob chris
you know you go see him pretend you're a
fan go oh dude i love your stand up yeah
psych gun out oh i'm addressing a 17
year old girl dude go into his place
[ __ ] him and then steal a bunch of [ __ ]
wait wait he doesn't he doesn't [ __ ]
underage girls though no dude no
no but actually actually that's funny
he's so chris is so far from being about
just turned 18 that morning that was
your birthday
chris is so far from being a pedophile
everyone should know this on the
internet by the way
he won't [ __ ] someone under 60. yeah no
chance
i've never seen chris hanging out with a
woman under 60 in my entire life he has
that 43 year yeah he stays 43 years
outside of
possible pedophilia yeah he loves that
and that's at 60 years to keep him safe
the more famous he gets
now he will doctor those 60 year old
chicks up i've seen him with
put fake tits on a 60 year old lady fake
teeth marriage could barely hold him up
i saw a woman with new eyes he had a
woman with brand new eyes yeah
how did she get new eyes he's like dude
yeah did that thing that he does
yeah i don't i don't you know do i like
do i like crystalia
you know he's like mustard yeah
he's like mustard
ain't no right way just the wrong way